[Music]
of all the words I know there's no word
that makes many of my colleagues more
emotional and prone to foam at the mouth
and then when I'm just about to say
consciousness a lot of scientists
dismiss this is complete BS and totally
irrelevant and and then other a lot of
others think this is like the central
thing have to worry about machines
getting conscious and so on what do I
think
I think consciousness is both irrelevant
and incredibly important let me explain
why first of all if you are chased by
heat-seeking missile it's completely
irrelevant to you whether this
heat-seeking missile is conscious
whether it's having a subjective
experience whether it feels like
anything to be that hit etq missile
because all you care about is what the
heat-seeking missile does not how it
feels and that shows that it's a
complete red herring to think that
you're safe from future AI if it's not
conscious to its behavior that you want
to make sure is aligned with your goals
on the other hand there is a way in
which consciousness is incredibly
important I feel and there's also a way
in which it's absolutely fascinating if
we rewind 400 years or so you know
Galileo he could have told you that if
you throw an apple and a hazelnut
they're gonna move exactly in this shape
of a parabola and you give you all the
math for it but he would have no clue
why the Apple was red and hazelnut was
brown or why the Apple was soft and
nasal it was hard
that seemed him beyond science and
science back 40 years ago could only
really say sensible things about this
very limited domain of a phenomena to do
with motion then came the Maxwell
equations and told us all about light
and colors and that became within the
realm of science then we got quantum
mechanics that told us why the Apple is
softer than the hazelnut and all other
properties of matter and
science is gradually conquered more and
more of the natural phenomenon if you
asking now what science can do it's
actually a lot faster to describe what
little it is that science cannot talk
about sensibly and I think the final
frontier actually is consciousness
people mean a lot of different things by
that word I simply mean subjective
experience experience of colors sounds
emotions and so on but it feels like
something to be me which is quite
separate from my behavior which I could
have even if I were a zombie and didn't
experience anything at all potentially
so why should you care about that I care
about it first of all because
fundamentally that's the basic thing
they know about the world my experiences
and I would love to understand
scientifically why that is and not just
leave it to philosophers and second it's
incredibly important also in terms of
purpose and meaning in the laws of
physics there is nothing about meaning
there's no equation for it and I feel
that we shouldn't look for our universe
to give meaning to us because it's us
who give meaning to our universe because
we are conscious and experiencing things
right our universe didn't used to be
conscious that used to be just a bunch
of stuff moving around and gradually
these incredibly complicated patterns
got arranged into our brains we woke up
but now our universe is aware of itself
we have galaxies out there they're
incredibly beautiful why are they
beautiful because we are consciously
aware of them we see them in our
telescopes if in the future we screw up
with technology you know our life goes
extinct then my universe will go back to
being meaningless and just a giant waste
of space as far as I'm concerned and
when it a colleague tells me that they
think science consciousness is BS I
challenge them to tell me what is wrong
with rape and torture and to explain
that to me without using the word
consciousness or the word experience
because if they can't talk about that
it's just that the whole thing that they
are saying is so bad is just the bunch
of electrons and quirks moving around in
some particular way rather than some
other
and what's so bad about that I feel the
only way we can actually have any
logical scientific foundation of ethics
morality purpose and meaning is
precisely in terms of experience in
terms of consciousness and this makes it
really important as we prepare for our
future to understand what this is and I
for one I think that this is actually
something that we can also ultimately
understand scientifically I don't think
that the difference between a living bug
in a dead bug is that the living bug has
some sort of secret life sauce in it I
think of the bugs as mechanisms and the
dead bug is the broken mechanism
similarly I think that what makes my
brain conscious but the food I ate which
got rearranged into my brain not wasn't
conscious isn't because they're made of
different kind of stuff it's the same
quarks rearranged right it's the pattern
into which they're arranged and I think
it's a scientific question what property
is does this pattern of information
processing have to have for there to be
a subjective experience there you can
imagine building a brain scanner
actually we have pretty good ones at MIT
where I work I'm having some software in
it which tests out whatever Theory you
have st. it for consciousness and makes
predictions for what you experience and
if I'm sitting in this machine and and
the computer screen tells me okay right
now I see information processing in your
brain indicating that you are
consciously aware of the thought of an
apple I'm like yeah that's right it's
correct and then it says I see
information about your heartbeat in your
brain when you're aware of this like no
I was not conscious of that II never
ruled out the theory that was
implemented in this software so it's
falsifiable that means it was a
scientific theory right if we can one
day find a theory like this and there
are some candidates on the market like
Julia - known as integrated information
theory for example if we ever find any
theory that keeps passing tests like
that and we start taking it seriously
and we can use it to Bill the
consciousness detector that's first of
all gonna be really useful physicians in
the emergency room would love it if they
get an unresponsive patient coming in
put them in the consciousness scanner
and figure out whether they have
locked-in syndrome and just can't
communicate but they're conscious or
whether there's nobody home and this
will also let us understand whether
future AI systems we build are conscious
and whether we should feel guilty or not
about switching them off some people
might prefer that their future home
helper robot is an unconscious zombie so
they don't have to feel guilty about
giving it boring chores or powering it
down some people might prefer that it's
conscious so that there can be a
positive experience in there and so that
they don't feel creeped out by this
machine just faking it you know and
pretending to be conscious even though
it's a zombie and most importantly in
the longer-term future if far from now
we have some we have lifes
that spread out from Earth to other
galaxies the whole cosmos is alive and
doing amazing things and although if
this life becomes the descendants of
humanity wouldn't it suck if it turns
out that this is all just Dom B's
wouldn't know consciousness and the
whole thing that we felt so good about
before we passed away was just a play
four empty benches I feel that we should
really really tackle this final frontier
of scientific ignorance the problem of
consciousness and get this stuff figured
out so we can shape the future which is
truly awesome not just kind of from the
outside the cool stuff seems to be
happening but that there's actually
someone home to experience all this
[Music]
you